you describe six stages in the evolution
of information processing in the
universe as you started to describe
can you maybe
talk through some of those stages from
the physics and chemistry to dna and
brains and then to the to the very end
to the very beautiful end
of this process well it actually gets
more rapid
so physics and chemistry that's how we
started um
so we had the very beginning of the
universe we had lots of electrons and
various things traveling around
and and that took actually many billions
of years
kind of jumping ahead here
to kind of
some of the last stages where we have
things like love and creativity
it's really quite remarkable that that
happens
but finally physics and chemistry
created biology
and dna
and now you had actually one type of
molecule that described the cutting edge
of this process
and we
go from physics and chemistry to biology
and finally biology created brains
i mean not all not everything that's
created by biology has a brain
but eventually brains came along
and all of this is happening faster and
faster yeah
it created increasingly complex
organisms
another key thing is actually not just
brains
but our thumb
uh
because because there's a lot of animals
with brains even bigger than humans
elephants have a bigger brain
whales have a bigger brain
but they've not created technology
because they don't have a thumb
so that's one of the really key elements
in the evolution of humans this uh
physical manipulator device right that's
useful for puzzle solving in the
physical reality so i could think i
could look at a tree and go oh i could
actually strip that branch down and
eliminate the leaves and
carve it tip on it and with great
technology
and you can't do that if you don't have
a thumb
yeah
so
thumbs up created technology
and technology also
had a memory
and now those memories are competing
with the
scale and scope of human beings
and ultimately we'll go beyond it
and then we're going to merge
human technology with
uh
with human intelligence
and understand how human uh
intelligence works which i think we
already do
and we're putting that into
uh
our human technology
so create the technology inspired by our
own intelligence and then that
technology supersedes us in terms of its
capabilities and we ride along or do do
you ultimately see it as we ride along
but a lot of people don't see that they
say well
okay you've got humans and you've got
machines and there's no way we can
ultimately compete with humans
and you can already see that
lisa doll who's like the best
go player in the world says he's not
going to play go anymore yeah
because playing go for human that was
like the ultimate in intelligence
because no one else could do that
uh
but now
a machine can actually go way beyond him
and so he says well there's no point
playing it anymore
that may be more true for games than it
is for life
i think there's a lot of benefit to
working together with ai in regular life
you